This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. How is everybody doing? What's been on your mind? What have you been thinking about recently? Stressed about, worried about. Maybe it's money, which is me at all time. your bills, how little your job is paying you, maybe it's your current living situation.
Your landlord is, quite frankly, an asshole. Your roommates are irritating you. You can't find a place to rent in your city. Maybe it is a breakup, a long-term relationship breakdown that, you know, you really thought you were going to be with this person forever. You had all these plans for the future and then suddenly it was over. You're facing heartbreak, kind of in the same place where you fell in love. All of these situations, states of minds, experiences seem kind of separate.
They seem to touch on different facets of dissatisfaction in our lives. But they have one thing in common, and that is that they all cause us to really consider the possibility of moving back home with our parents. Whether that is to save money because you can't find a place to live, you're going through a massive life transition. it is becoming a lot more common for 20-something-year-olds like you and I to revert back to living in their childhood home or sometimes not leaving at all until they're in their late 20s, sometimes even early 30s. Our living situation and our relationship with our parents are two major points of, I would say,
exploration and theory in psychology, especially during this decade that we call emerging adulthood, which is between the ages of 18 and 29, because these factors, these experiences, our living situation, our parents, they shape a lot about who we are. They shape a lot about what we're experiencing. In some ways, our entire state of mind and how we go about seeing the world. We're seeing a lot more research coming out about this, you know, in some of the pioneering studies on emerging adulthood, this chapter that we're in, that was conducted by the psychologist Jeffrey Arnett back in 2014. He talks about how two of the biggest events we go through or kind of battles that we endure
on our path to full-fledged adulthood are leaving home and redefining our relationship with our parents. It really used to be the case that people would move out of their parents home and never return. You know, for women, it might not be until they got married for men when they got a full-time paying job as the gender norm goes. But nowadays we're seeing a real societal shift whereby we are staying in the family home for much longer. About 50% of people in their 20s right now still live at home with their parents. And it's typically women who move out a lot earlier. But on average, you know, compared to like 40% of people who are living out of home two decades ago, there is this kind of decline in individuals who are seeing.
speaking out independent living during this decade. You know, living independently is no longer like a signifier of adulthood as it previously was because A, it's occurring later, but B, we're also boomeranging, right? We're moving out. We're leaving home. We're saying, my mom and dad, like I'm flying the nest. And like five years later, we're back where we kind of started. We're back in our childhood bedrooms.
It used to be the case that you couldn't even be labeled as an established adult until you had moved out of home. Like that was the biggest thing that researchers used as a signifier to say, okay, this person has grown up. But I think that that label, that kind of factor, that category no longer applies because there has been a real change in our willingness and our ability to kind of leave the nest. So let's talk about it today. I really want to firstly speak about why it is that a lot of us are delaying moving out, staying with our parents or being forced to move back home. Obviously, cost of living is a huge one, but we are also getting married later, you know, meaning that we might stay at home for longer before potentially meeting someone and settling down.
We're also seeing that although there has been a big growth in education levels, you know, more people are going to university. that hasn't translated into greater job security or financial insecurity. So I asked you guys on Instagram, there's almost, I think, 10,000 of you who answered me. And the question I asked is, why do you still live at home with your parents? Or why did you move back home with your parents?
Because about 50% of you said that they had moved out, you had moved out of home, and you had found your way back. So there were three main contributors factors, really, that stood out to me. firstly this one i'm going to just like put in its own category was covid of course huge life-changing medical epidemic event so i actually moved i moved out when i was 17 but i moved back home with my parents for three months when covid first began at like 20 years old and i think that was a lot of people's experiences like my mom had a total mental breakdown about me getting sick and dying and having no one
at, you know, no one around to help me because we knew so little about the virus. So I lasted about three months before. I literally begged for them to let me go back to Canberra where I was living at the time. And it was so strange because I could have left at any point, right? Like, I was an adult. My residential address was in Canberra. So it was like full within the law to travel back. But the dynamic of being at home made it feel like I had to get their permission that suddenly all of my agency, all of the authority I had over my life was kind of gone now that my parents were living under the same roof with me. So COVID was a big thing for a lot of us.
I think a lot of us did find ourselves moving back home around that time. It really was, though, I think a once-in-a-lifetime situation. I don't think that we're going to experience that again in our life, if not in our 20s. So we're going to count that as its own separate category, but the same. The second biggest reason that people, you know, told me about around why they either didn't move out or moved back home was finances and saving money. Oh my goodness. The world that we have inherited from our families, from our parents and their parents and
their parents before them is a broken world. There is an insane cost of living crisis going on. And I don't think I could name a city that isn't experiencing this or I could name a country that isn't experiencing this. So a lot of us aren't able to afford rent. I think in Sydney right now, the average rent is $750 a week when the average income is $1,400. And that is including people who are, you know, directors and executives and at the very high level of their career. I don't think the average 20-something-year-old like you and I is making $1,400 a week. So even if that was the case, almost half of your salary is going to just putting a roof over your head.
So that's not really accessible, is it? I think the rule of them is like a third or a quarter of your income should go towards paying rent. That doesn't seem like that is a $1,400 versus $750. That really is just taking out a huge chunk of what you're taking home each week. So we can't afford rent. We don't want to pay rent. You know, I think a lot of us are getting fed up of paying off somebody else's mortgage. whilst you're never going to be able to afford a place.
And I think that stark inequality that we are observing is creating a huge mental strain on the lives and health of young people in this generation primarily through, I think, an increased prevalence and incidence rate of financial anxiety, constantly being concerned or hyper-fixated on your income, on job security, on your debts, on your ability to afford necessities. I really don't think I can overstate how much financial anxiety this generation is experiencing that previous generations did not have to experience, whereby, you know, rent is one thing we can't afford, a roof over our head. We can't afford that without skimping on essentials like food or transport or healthcare or even a social life. Yes, your social life is a necessity.
It is essential being able to positively maintain your. relationships is not a luxury. So all of this kind of leads to a deep sense of unease, which makes it really hard to relax in our lives. And moving back home with our parents can relieve that by taking away the primary trigger, I would call it, for our worries about money, which is rent and bills. It's interesting because I saw this quote that said, living at home with your parents may be free, but you pay with your mental well-being. You might not be taking on any ten. financial responsibilities, but it does sometimes come at the small cost of your emotional health. And we're kind of forced into this really difficult trade-off during this decade.
Do we lose our health or do we lose our wealth? That's what it comes down to. The second biggest factor that people spoke about, which I was surprised about and then actually equally not as surprised about, was a breakup. I think when you start a life with someone in your 20s thinking it will be forever and it isn't, That is a significant disruptor to your sense of self, to your plans for the future, your plans for tomorrow, even. Sometimes we need the safety and security of our family to heal or to just give us a place to stay. I've seen so many friends enduring this recently whereby they've been with someone for like years and they've been living together, they're making plans for the future and then all of a sudden one of them turns around and calls it quits.
and they're forced with this like really awful, horrendous reality of having to clean out the place you live together, break a lease, you know, just push forward, do the daily things you used to experience with them by your side. That is its own unique form of psychological torture, especially in our 20s when it does kind of feel like a race to find the one. As much as I disagree with that, you know, there is a societal pressure to like have a mate, have a partner by the end of your 20s. So I think they're also battling this sense of like, well, now I'm back at square one. I have to begin this whole thing again. So that was another big factor, those people experiencing a breakup and that being a catalyst for moving home. And the final one was the beginning or the end of a huge life transition that kind of
prevents us from having permanent housing. A really great example of this is that period between graduation and starting a full-time job or perhaps not having a job lined up, not making any money, when you return overseas without a lease, you know, that is another real big catalyst for moving home. Some of us just want to be prepared, you know, to take our time until it feels absolutely right to move out, even if that means continuing to share a space, a home, our privacy, with our parents. There is one final factor that I actually want to talk about really quickly. A lot of you actually talked about how when your parents became ill, you felt this real
sense of obligation to take care of them as they got older, as they kind of took care of you when you were younger. I think those of us with a real strong sense of family values, family obligation, may feel compelled to kind of give up our independent lives in our 20s to very selflessly assist our parents. And I'm sure it's not the easiest to sit. but it definitely feels like the right one. So what are the consequences of this?
Why does living with our parents in our 20s seemingly take such a psychological, emotional, social, even sometimes physical toll? And there is a toll, a very scientifically observable one. So a recent Australian study published last year, one of the first of its kinds in Australia, looked at cohabitation between parents and young adults, so parents and children living together in the same house.
And they found that young adults, particularly those in their mid to late 20s, living with their parents, had poorer mental health than those living independently. And those mental health impacts become larger, the older that we get. So when you're 21 living with your parents, it might still be a struggle.
It's not that bad, compared to if you were 29 and living with your parents. And the authors attributed this to several factors. The first one is a sense of feeling stuck or feeling behind that you haven't yet reached a milestone that other people in your life have. You just feel like you can't progress your independent life. And I think that there's a real cultural element in that, especially in Western nations like Australia, like the US, like the UK,
like Canada, all of those, whereby historically and psychologically, Western societies really value independence and they see a dependence on the family home and on family resources as a failure whereby more Eastern cultures are a lot more collective, you know, collectivism. That's a big part of their identity as a community, which is we help each other out. It's not unnormal, unheard of, I guess, for people in their 40s, to still be living with their parents or to have their parents move in with them. So I really think that the impact you're going to feel is really dependent on a couple of things. Obviously culture, expectation, that's a big one.
But I also think the reason that we tend to struggle comes down to the innate nature of a parent-child relationship and how that develops in our 20s when we are no longer a child by age, but we are a child by relationship to our parents living under their roof, feeling like we're not fully able to express or practice our freedom. We're not fully able to be recognized by them as an adult, but rather as the child that they raised, the teenager that they scolded, the young adult that they still feel a sense of protectiveness or control over. Once again, this environment positions you like relationally as a child.
You are still that 16, 17, 18 year old version of yourself that your parents could control and could send to your room and could ground. Because the environment in which that relationship and that dynamic occurred is the same, even if you have matured and grown older. Our relationship with our parents, I think, is always going to be hierarchical. They are at the top. They have more power because of just the nature of the fact that they, you know, they gave birth to you, they created you. They chose you if you were adopted. You know, there was an active choice by them to have you as a child and they got to
implant you with their values. Your childhood was formed by their choices. They financially supported you for many years. And so when you spend that first 18 years of your life having to listen to them, perhaps having to conceal parts of you to still seem like a child in their mind, arguing with them, needing their permission, that doesn't show. shift overnight. I think that's why we see, like, at the moment that we're back within the orbit of our family,
we, like, regress significantly. We become very dependent. We argue like we did when we were a bratty teenager. We don't pick up our laundry. We just, we become this version of ourselves that we left behind. But when we come back into the relationship, it positions us as being immature, as still being a child. In fact, I actually read this really fascinating piece of work in which one psychologist noted that it's really common for people to regress psychologically, especially when faced with
tension or conflict within the family. We revert back to the old patterns that we know that we have rehearsed and remembered from childhood because this is the only way that we've ever related to our parents in these situations. It's so interesting because I was having like an argument with my mom a couple months back and like I would say this is a weird thing I'm very good at arguing like in a mature way like with my partner with my friends with I don't really argue you know what I mean like it's and when I do it's safe and it's respectful and I know when to take breaks with my parents it's just like I'm this feral human because it's just like I'm this child again who doesn't have emotional regulation because our relationship allows me to fall back into that I always always
felt really embarrassed about it. Turns out this regression is actually very universal. It's reflecting our longest relationship, the one that we've had with our caregivers. And with that, a very deeply embedded pattern of behavior. And it's very, very hard to break, especially if you continue to live at home and you haven't yet separated from the family unit because that would give you kind of a form or a way of psychological separation in which you would have the space to form your own values, to form your own beliefs, deform your own attitudes beyond the family unit that need to separate socially,
physically, psychologically, gets stronger and stronger the older we get because that part of us that wants to be an established adult who wants independence, who wants to decide what they have to dinner, who wants to decide whether they're going to leave a mess or not. That gets harder to ignore, even if we know that we are saving on rent, even if there is a practical, consideration there. So this is what the very famous psychologist Eric Erickson calls the battle between identity versus confusion, whereby we start to really push back against our childhood, childhood identity and discover who we are beyond the wants and beliefs of our parents. And we need to overcome this conflict between identity and confusion in order to progress in our lives. This used
to occur when we were about 18. But the fact is, is that adulthood is being delayed for a lot of us because the milestones that normally defined our 20s are shifting. So we're feeling this conflict and this urge for separation later on, perhaps, but more intensely. That's the argument that's been made in recent years. And I think the luxury of having our own say over our environment, which we didn't get as children, it becomes a necessity the older we get. And having our own space becomes very psychologically important because your own space is an expression of our emerging identity. Having our own space allows for the expansion of our personal boundaries onto our external environment. So it's not just about how you want your parents to treat you,
it's how you want you, like the control you have over your space, the control you have over your furniture, over your mess. I think having private and personal space is one thing. but having enough of it is another thing, you know, like you may still have that sense of control over your bedroom that's at your home. But you need more space than that as you get older because a private life cannot be lived in one bedroom alone, especially when someone can easily walk in or can maybe hear through the walls, especially when that bedroom is one that your parents essentially own. You just don't have room to expand.
You don't feel as if you have the ability to actually be you. And I think that can lead us to feeling very claustrophobic, alienated, maybe stuck. It's really interesting because there was this study done on this that estimates that we need at least 15 square meters of personal space, minimum as we go to. So that's about the size of one and a half school buses. You're probably not getting that with your parents living in your childhood bedroom. Privacy is another thing I want to focus on within that. So privacy is a really interesting concept because it's a really interesting concept because it's, is quite literally defined as a fundamental human right, meaning that there are major bodies
across the world from the UN to major psychological societies to the human rights commissions of the world that see it as essential for well-being, essential for human safety, human security, but finally, human fulfillment. And it's not that our parents are deliberately withholding our privacy, in most cases at least, just that there is not much private. privacy to be had by nature of living at home, by nature of sharing living spaces. And I think that we feel that especially when it comes to our relationships, both romantic and platonic. I think inviting friends over becomes a lot harder because you can't, you know, use the space exactly how you'd like. Your parents may kind of always be lingering in the corner. You can't necessarily talk openly about whatever you want. You can't behave
however you want. There is still an illusion you want to maintain with your parents that you are a child. There is still a way that you are kind of expected implicitly to act. This is not the place to be uninhibited. This is the place to be cautious. Additionally, unless our friends are particularly close with our parents, because I know that does happen. Sometimes you can feel quite on edge when you visit a friend's house and their mom like opens the door or their dad is like sitting on the couch whilst you're cooking dinner or like he's like I don't know going to the bathroom whilst you're like trying to catch up over a glass of wine you always have a sense that you're not just speaking to your friend there are other ears that are tuned in so it's hard to really get to that level of depth
where vulnerability exists things might feel strained now romantic relationships are a whole other bag of i don't know bag of buttons bag of bones and i think that living at home can really change the whole trajectory of what happens between us and someone that we're dating, particularly when we start courting someone, start feeling them out, start sleeping with them, it's kind of awkward to be like, do we want to take this back home? Do we want to extend this date in a place we're more comfortable, by the way I live with my parents? You know, let's be real, dating people casually. It usually means you're sleeping together or you're doing something intimate in that sense.
You can't really, like, invite them back to your place without, like, fully introducing them to your parents on, like, date three or five. And that completely, once again, speeds up the intensity of the relationship in an instant whereby people who live alone or with roommates. You know, you have time to, like, feel this person out. You have time to date them before they meet the parents, you know, whereas if you're living at home, especially when it comes to sex, you know, like, they might be meeting them pretty soon. And it's also a bit of like a weird thing to like have sex in your parents' house thinking that like they might be able to hear what's going on. You kind of want to maintain this like facade that you're not a sexual creature almost for their peace of mind. And that makes it harder. It makes it like a lot harder to do the deed.
So I remember when I moved back with my parents, not for very long. It was like probably only three weeks over the summer after I finished my degree. I was dating this guy whose parents also live. lived in Melbourne. And so, of course, we're both in Melbourne at the same time. We keep seeing each other over the holidays. But because both of our parents were always home, we could like, we couldn't have sex. And then one night, I snuck him in through the side gate to this literal shed, like this shed like studio thing we have in our backyard. And he slept overnight on this blow-up mattress and the next morning, for some reason, because literally no one ever goes into this room,
my mom walks in and there is me in the sky like naked on a camping mattress and it was so funny because my mom always had this rule that her and my dad needed to meet anyone who stayed over so like boyfriends and such I guess she did kind of meet him in a strange way but yeah it was embarrassing and it felt like this weird curtain that you have around your private life is like pulled aside and it's kind of ghastly and it can also lead to some intrusive questions which I think is just sometimes our parents attempting to connect with us, but it feels really awkward and embarrassing. And there can also be judgment within that.
If your parents' attitude to dating is also different to yours, which I think generationally is bound to happen, they might not understand more modern dating practices like hooking up, like situationships, like one-night stands, friends with benefits. Or maybe they do understand. and that's the problem. They know that what might be taking place is transactional and it's an uncomfortable mutual acknowledgement at that stage. All of this comes down to once again, the innate child parent relationship dynamic. That's what's playing out in this situation as we seek opportunities
to redefine ourselves, to expand our personal lives through our relationships, to make our lives our own, to kind of create new values for ourselves, new environments, whatever it is. our childhood environment remains the same and it remains the environment that we're in. So I think that is a big adjustment, especially if you've moved back home after independent living. It's a bit like a yo-yo, right? Like you've gone the full length of independence. You've reached the full limit of what it means to live independently right to the end of the string. You've adjusted to the sense of liberation and freedom and choice and then you're kind of pulled or yo-yoed back.
And that reverse adjustment is a lot harder because you know what's out there. You know the grass is actually greener and you live with this realistic comparison between living, I don't want to say living alone, you could be living with roommates, but living independently and living with family. I think whatever your situation cohabiting with your parents is obviously a scale. Some people I spoke to loved it. We're going to talk about that in a minute. But the main factor that seemed to determine enjoyment versus dissatisfaction is the type of parents that you have and your relationship with them. Parents who were strict or controlling in childhood, who are so-called helicopter parents, are probably not going to grow out of that because I think a part of their makeup is this sense of
neurosis, this sense of needing control and authority and to be in charge. And that part of who they are, that part of their personality does not disappear as their children get older. That makes it especially hard to seek out freedom in a cohabitation. situation with your parents, or to even have a fruitful conversation about what needs to change to ensure you guys have a positive relationship because they're not really open to discussion, right? And that may have been the case always. Perhaps they just never really got you. They didn't respect your identity. They didn't really respect what you were doing, what you wanted
神经症，这种对控制、权威以及掌管一切的需求感。而他们性格中这一部分、他们个性中的这一部分并不会随着孩子的长大而消失。这使得在与父母同居的情况下寻求自由变得尤为困难，甚至很难就为了确保你们拥有积极关系而需要改变的地方进行富有成效的对话，因为他们并不真正愿意讨论，对吧？这种情况可能一直都存在。也许他们从来没有真正理解过你。他们不尊重你的身份。他们并不真正尊重你在做的事情、你想要的
to do in your life, your decisions. So that creates attention and it creates conflict that is heightened in close quarters, whereby each of you is trying to enforce your view and stand your ground, and no one's willing to shift. And I think that that doesn't happen when you don't live with them. It might happen to some extent, but they don't know everything that's going on. They don't have as many opportunities for contact to say what they think, even if it's not what you want to hear. They don't have as many opportunities to be intrusive. So I think that that's a really common thing that happens, whereby it feels oppressive. almost to have their constant, not a judgment, but their constant opinion.
生活中的事情以及你的决定。因此，这会产生紧张情绪，并在近距离接触中加剧冲突，你们每个人都在试图强加自己的观点并坚守立场，而没有人愿意妥协。我想，当你不同他们住在一起时，这种情况是不会发生的。某种程度上可能会发生，但他们并不知道正在发生的一切。他们没有那么多接触的机会去发表他们的看法，即使这些看法并不是你想听的。他们没有那么多机会去进行干涉。所以我认为这是一种非常普遍的现象，会让人觉得压抑。不断地听到他们的意见，虽然算不上指责，但也让人吃力。
And they may also kind of engage in a bit of guilt tripping. They may lord things over you. That's a really common thing when we live at home. You know, you need to do this for me because you live under my roof. I paid for this. So you should show this house and respect. You should do this. You should come home before 12.
而且他们也可能会进行一点情绪勒索。他们可能会居高临下地把事情压在你身上。当我们住在家里时，这是一种非常普遍的现象。你知道的，你得为我做这个，因为你住在我的屋檐下。这房子是我买的。所以你应该对这个家表现出尊重。你应该做这个。你应该在12点之前回家。
They have the power because they own the home. And this kind of guilt tripping is a form of manipulation, even if it's implicit, even if they don't understand that's what they're doing, maybe because your parents don't have the skills or the language to assertively communicate their feelings. And so they resort to implicitly controlling your actions through guilt. And it leaves both people feeling terrible. It leaves you feeling terrible.
因为他们拥有这个家，所以他们掌握着权力。这种情绪勒索是一种操纵形式，即使它是隐含的，即使他们并不明白这就是他们在做的事，也许是因为你的父母缺乏自信地表达他们感受的技巧或语言。因此，他们诉诸于通过内疚感来隐性控制你的行为。这让双方都感觉糟糕透顶。让你感觉糟糕透顶。
It leaves them actually not saying what they mean. And they've looked into this. There was a study done in 2013, a study done in 2014. that confirmed the initial findings that when guilt tripping happens frequently in a parent-child relationship, it leads to resentment and it leads to a loss of closeness and intimacy. And it leads you feeling like you need to get away, that you don't want to come back. There can also just be this elevated sense of conflict, right? Like we were talking about with them giving out their opinion, you feel very stuck because you don't have the distance
这也让他们无法真正表达内心的真实想法。对此他们进行过研究。2013年进行过一项研究，2014年也进行过一项研究，这些研究证实了最初的发现：当情绪勒索在父母与孩子的关系中频繁发生时，会导致怨恨，并导致亲密感和紧密联系的丧失。它会让你觉得你需要离开，你不想再回来了。冲突也可能会有这种升高的趋势，对吧？就像我们刚才讨论的，他们发表自己的意见，你会感到非常无助，因为你没有那种
that people who live out of home have. And I think that sometimes it can be very revealing of a lot of repressed childhood trauma or missteps or resentment that is bound to come up in such close quarters. It's just that now you have the adult understanding of your experiences and the adult rationality to know that like your parents probably may have been in the wrong
独居之人才有的距离感。而且我认为，有时这会极大地暴露许多被压抑的童年创伤、失误或怨恨，这些情绪注定会在如此狭小的空间里爆发。只是现在你拥有了对经历的成年人的理解，以及成年人的理性，知道你的父母可能确实做错了
to see what occurred that could have been done better. And your parents are not going to see it. it the same way. So it's just this like, it can often promote like this rehashing of negative, difficult behavioral patterns between you and your mom and your dad and your caregiver that there has been no circuit breaker. There has been no psychological separation to stop this from occurring. Again, I just think this goes to show how your relationship with your parents can become strained when you live under the same roof because we're not able to assert
从而看出原本可以做得更好的地方。而你的父母却不会以同样的方式看待它。所以这就像是，它经常会促使你、你妈妈、你爸爸以及你的照顾者之间重新上演那些消极的、困难的行为模式，而这中间并没有任何缓冲机制。没有任何心理上的隔离来阻止这一切再次发生。再说一次，我认为这恰恰说明了当你住在同一个屋檐下时，你与父母的关系是如何变得紧张的，因为我们无法坚持
or practice our independence. We still feel childlike. We still feel stuck. Our relationships may suffer but sometimes maybe it's worth it to you to save some money to not drown in debt, to have housing stability. And one part of it that we haven't discussed
或练习我们的独立性。我们仍然觉得自己像个孩子。我们仍然觉得被困住了。我们的关系可能会受损，但有时为了省钱、为了不陷入债务危机、为了拥有稳定的住房，这一切可能对你来说又是值得的。我们尚未讨论的一个方面是
is that there are benefits. Some people just really like living with their parents. And I think that that is also just a completely valid perspective that I'm going to talk about after this short break, we're also going to talk about some tips to cope, how to assert boundaries, how to get the most out of this situation. We will be back shortly.
其实这样做也有好处。有些人就是真的很喜欢和父母住在一起。我认为这也是一个完全合理的观点，我将在短暂的休息后讨论这一点，我们还将讨论一些应对的技巧、如何坚持界限、如何充分利用这种状况。我们稍后回来。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers. and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这些伪科学主导着健康产业。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette.
收听《2%》。名字就是数字 2 PERCENT，可在 IHeart Radio 苹果播客或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 MTV 音乐录影带大奖上戳小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英国。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析其前因后果，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·Hill大谈80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上，所以……感谢你把这句话说完。是的，我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeart
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch.
不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，是因为你们觉得在地球上做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同信任层面的问题。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，由我基尔·盖恩斯带你就治愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。由此开启了一场长达数年的庭审之战以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marincini.
L 斯女士，这份特定的测试你伪造了两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马林奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 Iheart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。
If 50% of 20-something-year-olds are living at home, I don't think all 50% are struggling because there are definitely some perks. beyond just lessening, you know, our financial anxiety or for temporary housing, there are people who I know, who I'm friends with, who actively choose this lifestyle and living arrangement, even if they can afford to do otherwise, even if they have all available opportunities to live out of home. Again, I wanted to hear from you guys, the listeners, about your experience with this, and you came through, you provided some really fascinating insights. A big benefit that was spoken about is knowing that you're always going to have a support system
如果50%的二十几岁年轻人住在家里，我认为这50%的人并不都在苦苦挣扎，因为除了减轻我们的财务焦虑或提供临时住所之外，确实还有一些额外的好处。我认识的一些人、我的朋友们，他们主动选择这种生活方式和居住安排，即使他们负担得起其他选择，即使他们拥有在外面独居的所有可能机会。再次强调，我想听听你们这些听众关于这方面的经历，而你们也没有让我失望，提供了一些非常迷人且深刻的见解。大家经常谈到的一个巨大好处是，你知道自己将永远拥有一个支持系统
and someone to turn to for comfort. That is something a lot of us lack in our 20s when we do feel especially disconnected and lonely. Having someone who is always around is a blessing is really special, especially if you're struggling mentally after a breakup or because of a mental health condition or if you're chronically ill or sick, I do think that that is a massive pro of living with your parents in your 20s. And honestly, I love being babyed by my mom sometimes when she comes to town. It feels really good to kind of switch off a part of my brain that is adult
并且有可以倾诉和寻求安慰的人。这正是我们在二十多岁时，当感到特别失联和孤独时，许多人所缺乏的。有一个时刻陪伴在你身边的人是一种福气，非常特别，尤其是如果你在分手后精神状态挣扎，或者因为心理健康状况不佳，或者如果你患有慢性病，我认为这绝对是在二十多岁时与父母同居的一个巨大优势。老实说，当妈妈来镇上时，我真的很喜欢被她像婴儿一样照顾。关掉大脑中成年人那部分的感觉
because I suddenly have like my protector here. I have someone older. I have someone wiser, someone who's definitely going to pay for dinner. Some of you people also said that you are actually really good friends with your parents, which actually tends to occur more the older we get. So there's been some research on this that shows that a level of contact and connection with our parents tends to dip around 20 to 25, but then steadily rises thereafter. That dip, and they do say sometimes it begins much earlier around 17, but 17 to 25 is like when we most likely see it, it's a large range,
真的很棒，因为我突然有了我的保护者在这里。我有一个年长的人。我有一个更明智的人，一个绝对会请吃晚饭的人。你们中的一些人还说，你们实际上和父母是非常好的朋友，这种情况实际上随着我们年龄的增长而越来越常见。对此有一些研究表明，我们与父母的联系和沟通水平在20到25岁左右往往会下降，但此后会稳步上升。这种下降（他们有时说这种下降开始得更早，大约在17岁左右，但17到25岁是我们最常看到这种情况的时期，跨度很大），
but most of us will fall into it. That dip is probably attributable to the need for. for distance in early adulthood to form an identity that is separate from our caregivers. But I think we do truly appreciate how valuable family is as we get older, how helpful they are. Living with our parents can be quite special because we do have a deep connection that we can nourish and which can bring us a lot of comfort, especially as they're getting older, I think there is a sense of like, I don't want to miss out on this time because we become more acutely aware that we're not going to have them forever. if you have kids as well, they're such a great help.
但我们大多数人都会落在这个区间内。这种下降可能归因于成年早期对距离的需求，以便形成一个独立于照顾者的身份。但我认为，随着年龄的增长，我们确实真正意识到了家庭有多么宝贵，他们是多么乐于助人。与父母同居可以非常特殊，因为我们确实有着深厚的联系，我们可以去滋养它，这能给我们带来极大的慰藉，尤其是随着他们日渐衰老，我认为有一种这样的心态：我不想错过这段时光，因为我们更加敏锐地意识到我们不会永远拥有他们。如果你也有孩子的话，他们会是绝佳的帮手。
I heard from a few people who were single mothers. And honestly, I admire you guys so much. I'm sure parents are really great help, a godsend at times. And it just comes down to the sharing of responsibilities. You know, living in a house by yourself, even with other people, I don't think we kind of appreciate how much work it is. Like, I really was not grateful enough for what my parents did for me back then. in terms of paying bills, keeping on top of cleaning, keeping on top of maintenance, keeping
我听过一些单亲妈妈的故事。老实说，我非常佩服你们。我相信父母真的是很大的帮助，有时简直是雪中送炭。这其实就归结于责任的分担。你知道，一个人住在一栋房子里，哪怕跟其他人一起住，我们也不会意识到这需要付出多少劳动。就像我当年真的不够感激父母为我所做的一切，无论是交账单、打扫卫生、维持房屋状况，还是
on top of laundry, keeping on top of just like the most randomous things, locking the door. Like, there is a lot to be done. And I think that when we share that responsibility, there is obviously less of a burden on us. And just like a sense of community and belonging that we don't, you know, we tend to stray from in our early 20s. It's like an unconditional love that money really can't buy. So what do we do to make this experience more pros than cons? What are some of the behavioral, psychological, emotional strategies for getting the most out of this time?
处理衣物，以及处理各种琐碎的事情，比如锁门。有太多事情要做了。我认为当我们分担责任时，我们身上的负担显然就会减轻。而且，那种社区感和归属感是我们往往在二十出头时倾向于忽略的。这是一种金钱买不到的无条件。那么，我们该怎么做才能让这段经历利大于弊呢？有哪些行为、心理和情感策略能让我们这段时间过得最有价值？
Even if this is not your first choice for a living situation, you can make it better. And I want to talk about six tips to help you manage. So the first one is to actually keep your parents updated on your life. I do believe that a lot of like the inquisitiveness, the curiosity, what feels like intrusiveness, comes down to them just wanting to know you. And so make it so that they're not surprised. I think that creates tension when they're used to having that, you know,
即使这不是你居住环境的首选，你也可以让它变得更好。我想谈谈六个帮助你应对的建议。首先，实际上是让父母了解你的近况。我相信许多盘问、好奇、甚至是让人觉得越界的感觉，归根结底都只是因为他们想更多地了解你。所以，提前告诉他们，让他们不要感到意外。当他们习惯了……我猜最好的表达方式是，
they plan to have this house by themselves once they were past a certain age for their children to leave the nest, I guess is like the best way to put it. And so used to being there makes them feel like they still have some kind of right to know what's going on. So invite them in. So they don't feel like they have to force them. themselves in through opinion and judgment, whether that is telling them about your dating life
他们原本计划在孩子离巢、达到一定年龄后，自己享受这栋房子。习惯了独自居住让他们觉得他们依然有某种权利去了解发生了什么。所以，邀请他们走进来。这样他们就不会觉得必须通过发表意见和评判来强行介入，无论是跟你聊聊你的感情生活
in not as much detail, but in some detail, or about your friends or about how work is going. I think that that just creates open channels for communication and it stops them from feeling like, oh, you're just there eating my food, you're ungrateful, you're not coming to me for the emotional support that I think they do kind of want to offer. The other thing is to articulate boundaries. I feel like everyone knows this, but sometimes we're not great at knowing when to set a boundary and about what, right? Like we know we feel uncomfortable, but we're not sure what kind of behavior would prevent that level of like uncomfortableness
不需要事无巨细，但要聊一些细节，或者聊聊你的朋友、工作进展。我认为这创造了开放的沟通渠道，能打消他们的这种想法：“你只是来这里吃我的饭，你不懂得感恩，你没有来找我寻求我其实很想提供的情感支持。”另一件事是明确界限。我觉得每个人都知道这一点，但有时我们并不擅长知道什么时候该设定界限以及该针对什么设定界限，对吧？就像我们知道自己感觉不舒服，但却不确定什么样的行为可以防止那种不舒服
and distress from happening. The best way to tell when a boundary needs to be set is by noticing your feelings and when something, you can feel something in your body. When you feel uncomfortable, that is your brain telling you that something needs to be fixed or rectified. That is your best alarm system right there. So what about that moment? The words said, the situation.
和痛苦再次发生。判断什么时候需要设定界限的最好方法，是去注意你的感受以及身体发出信号的时刻。当你感到不舒服时，那是你的大脑在告诉你，有些事情需要修复或纠正。那就是你最好的警报系统。那么，当时具体发生了什么？说过的话，当时的处境，
made you feel upset, made you feel angry, made you feel frustrated. Was it because they crossed a line in terms of like asking about your personal life? Was it because they guilt tripped you? Was it because they asked you to do something that you didn't want to do? Once you can articulate what it is that made you uncomfortable, then you can set a boundary. Not before. You have to actually know what it was that was frustrating, what it was that made you angry. You need to express that boundary before it can have effect.
让你感到不安、愤怒、沮丧。是因为他们越界打听你的私事吗？是因为他们对你进行内疚引导吗？是因为他们要求你做你不想做的事吗？一旦你能清晰地表达是什么让你感到不舒服，你就可以设定界限了。而不是在这之前。你必须真正明白是什么让你沮丧，是什么让你生气。在界限生效之前，你需要先表达出来。
it might be like hey I don't want you to speak to me like that I'm not a child anymore so when we're having conversations please speak to me as you would speak to one of your friends or to you know my dad or to my mom or it might be hey like actually I understand that I'm living under your roof but I'm still an adult and I don't need a curfew I don't need you to tell me what to do can we have some respect around allowing me to live independently I think it takes courage to do that but it will improve your life and just even speaking about what it is that's upset you does allow you to come back and reference that and say like hey we talked about this and we spoke about the consequences of what would happen if this wasn't fixed which outcome
可能会是这样：“嘿，我不想你这样跟我说话，我不再是个小孩子了。所以当我们谈话时，请像跟你的朋友说话，或者像跟……你知道的，我爸或我妈说话那样跟我说话。”或者可能是：“嘿，其实我明白我住在你的屋檐下，但我依然是个成年人，我不需要门禁，我不需要你告诉我要做什么。在允许我独立生活这件事上，我们能互相尊重吗？”我认为这需要勇气，但这会改善你的生活。仅仅是谈论是什么让你心烦意乱，就能让你以后回过头来参考并说：“嘿，我们谈过这个，也谈过如果没有解决的话会有什么后果。你想要哪个结果
would you like here do you want the outcome where i move out and we don't speak anymore or where our relationship is incredibly tense or do you want the outcome where we do have open channels of communication and we can speak about this like adults rather than like I'm still a child. This also leads me to my next tip. When you fight, don't go down, stay high. I understand as we spoke about, it's very easy to regress and become quite childlike in conflict with our parents. This is your reminder to be calm, to take a break, take a step back, go for a walk, and to not let your parents put you in the position where you feel like you need to be emotional. immature. They might be very high, I don't know, I feel like sometimes parents can be very much like
呢？”你想要我搬出去然后我们再也不说话的结果，还是我们之间的关系变得异常紧张的结果？或者你想要我们拥有开放的沟通渠道、能像成年人一样谈论此事（而不是把我当成小孩）的结果？这也引出了我的下一个建议。当你们争吵时，不要降低格调，保持高姿态。我理解正如我们所谈到的，在与父母发生冲突时，我们很容易退化，变得像个小孩子。这是对你的提醒：保持冷静，休息一下，退后一步，出去散散步，不要让父母把你置于那种让你觉得自己需要表现得情绪化或不成熟的境地。他们可能会表现得很傲慢，我不知道，我感觉有时候父母真的很
up on their high horse, very much like, oh, you don't understand, dismissive. That's really freaking angry when you feel like you are still an independent person. So don't let them put you into a place where you confirm that you are still a child, where you confirm that you are not able to have constructive conversations with them. So these next two, I think, are really practical. The first one is to take on some adult responsibilities in the house so you don't feel like you've lost control over your environment, that you're not doing something, not acting to maintain a home, and pay some rent so that you still feel like you have some right for ownership over your space and that you're contributing. Now, obviously, a big factor that we spoke about was that
高高在上，非常喜欢摆架子，说“哦，你不懂”，并且充满贬低。当你觉得自己明明已经是一个独立的人时，这真的会让人超级抓狂。所以，不要让他们把你推到一个位置去印证你还是个孩子，印证你无法与他们进行建设性的对话。接下来的这两点，我觉得非常实用。第一点是承担一些家里成年人的责任，这样你就不会觉得失去了对环境的控制，不会觉得你什么都没做、没有参与维护一个家；同时支付一些房租，这样你仍然觉得自己对这个空间拥有某种所有权，并且你是在做贡献。当然，我们讨论过的一个巨大因素是，
we move in with our parents, we stay home with our parents because we can't afford to move out, so how can we afford to pay rent? I'm not saying pay the 750, that's the average weekly rent in Sydney or whatever, pay like 50 bucks. Or put like $20 where you buy, $20 doesn't buy that many groceries anymore. I don't know, $100 where you buy all the groceries for the week. So that you still feel like there is a level of entitlement you have over this space because you are making some kind of financial commitment contribution
我们搬去跟父母同住，我们留在父母家里是因为我们买不起房子，那我们怎么还付得起房租？我不是说要付750块，那是悉尼每周的平均房租之类的，你可以付个50块左右。或者花20块买点……20块现在也买不了多少杂货了。我不知道，花100块把这一周所有的杂货都买了吧。这样你仍然会觉得你对这个空间拥有某种理所应当的权利，因为你做出了一些经济上的承诺和贡献，
that increases a sense of ownership for you so that this is your space. You don't own it but you're contributing to it. You have an investment in it. do things outside of the home this one is probably the most important of all of them don't let your identity get tired up with being an adult who still lives in your parents house like i know sometimes it can feel kind of strange maybe shameful you know maybe not what you wanted but that doesn't mean that you can't still get the most out of your 20s right you should join a social club a book club late night sport volunteering rock climbing i think that these activities allow you to feel like you still
这会增强你的所有权感，让这里变成你的空间。你虽然不拥有它，但你在为它做贡献。你在其中有投资。在屋外做一些事情，这可能是所有建议中最重要的一点。不要让你的身份与“一个仍然住在父母家里的成年人”紧密捆绑在一起。我知道有时候这可能会觉得有点奇怪，也许有点羞耻，也许不是你想要的，但这并不意味着你不能充分享受你的20岁，对吧？你应该加入一个社交俱乐部、读书俱乐部、深夜运动俱乐部、做义工、去攀岩。我认为这些活动能让你觉得自己依然
have a sense of self outside of the home that you can still be free you can still be your own person you can still be you know in this phase and this chapter of exploration and like journeying into adulthood beyond the orbit of the family that's really really valuable to keep up a sense of like keep up a sense of like not independence but a sense of engagement maybe with the life that's going on around you and with other people who are maybe living out of home maybe aren't just other people like our age um put a lock on your door someone actually sent this in that's just like a small assertion of privacy right like sometimes it's nice to just know that mom isn't going to like go through your like naughty drawer like when you're when you're not at home i understand if it's a rental property
在家庭的轨道之外，依然拥有自我意识，依然是自由的，依然可以做你自己，依然可以在探索和迈向成年的人生章节中做你自己，而不仅仅局限在家庭的范围内。保持这种感觉真的非常非常珍贵——不是保持独立感，而是保持一种参与感，与周围生活以及其他可能已经搬出去住的人、或者不只是和我们同龄的人保持联系。在你的门上装个锁。有人真的把这个建议发了过来，这只是一种对隐私的小小维护，对吧？有时候，知道当你不在家时，妈妈不会去翻你的“恶趣味抽屉”，这种感觉挺好的。我理解如果是租来的房子，
that might be harder, but you can get a removable lock that you can take off before the lease expires. Just some way to assert that like this is my space, like we said, personal space is vital, psychologically, very vital the older we get. So that's really valuable to like assert that like this is my oasis, this is sacred to me. I can use this space as my own. And finally, have some productive check-ins with your parents, with your parents, with your family the same way you would have check-ins with roommates right living under one roof people cohabitating is a melting pot is a like a kindling for conflict like something is going to go wrong because everyone has different preferences different ways of expressing their emotions expressing their needs
这可能会更难，但你可以买一个在租约到期前可以拆卸的便携锁。用某种方式宣告“这是我的空间”，正如我们所说，私人空间至关重要。随着年龄的增长，心理上的私人空间非常重要。因此，宣告“这是我的绿洲，这是我的神圣领地，我可以把这里当成我自己的空间”是非常有价值的。最后，和你的父母进行一些富有成效的定期沟通，就像你和室友同在一个屋檐下时所做的那样。同居是一个大熔炉，是冲突的引火物——总会有事情出错，因为每个人都有不同的偏好、不同的表达情绪和需求的方式，
different stresses going on in their life that might be triggered or you know kind of broken by someone else is just doing something small, right? It's the straw that breaks the camels back as the saying goes. So you do actually need to still be actively communicating about what's going on in each other's lives. What needs to be done around the house so that there isn't a level of resentment that builds up and spills over? What people are dissatisfied about? Should there be a cleaning roster? Like, not to turn it into a sharehouse, but I think the secret to any good relationship is really just having the guts to just be like, this is uncomfortable, but we're going to talk about it anyways because it's like a really painful massage. You know you're going to feel better.
生活中有着不同的压力，这些压力可能会被别人微小的举动所触发或打破，对吧？正如俗话所说，这是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。所以，你确实仍然需要积极沟通彼此的生活中正在发生什么。家里需要做哪些事情，才不会积累怨恨并最终爆发？大家对什么不满意？是不是应该搞个值日表？倒不是要把家里变成合租房，但我认为任何良好关系的关键，其实都在于有勇气说：“这让人很不舒服，但我们还是要谈一谈”，就像是一次虽然痛苦但有效的按摩。你知道做完之后你会感觉更好。
You know that the future outcome is going to be a lot more enjoyable. I think living at home with your parents in your 20s takes a bit of courage. It definitely takes a lot of emotional regulation and it takes effort. It takes effort to still feel like you are independent and free and live in your best life. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I really enjoyed blurring this because I do believe that our living situation and our relationship with our parents are two of the most significant contributors to our mental well-being in early or emerging adulthood, especially when they intertwine, especially when they interact. I want to hear more about your experiences. If there's something we've missed, please reach out. This is such a fascinating
你知道未来的结果会愉快得多。我认为在20岁时和父母同住需要一点勇气。它绝对需要大量的心理调节和付出努力。要觉得自己依然独立、自由并过着最棒的生活，是需要付出努力的。所以我真心希望你喜欢这一期节目。我录制得很开心，因为我相信我们的居住环境以及我们与父母的关系，是影响我们早期或初显期成年阶段心理健康的两个最重要的因素，尤其是当它们交织在一起、相互影响的时候。我想听到更多关于你们经历的故事。如果有我们遗漏的地方，请联系我们。这是一个如此迷人的
area of research, especially as we're seeing cohabitation, rise we're seeing young adults move back more frequently. I think it all points to like a broader societal shift in which it's hard for 20-somethings to be as independent as our parents were. And that's not to say that we don't want to be, right? It's because of a whole range of factors like finances, like cost of living, that interact with our personhood and interact with the decisions that we are able to make. So I really hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope that you learned something. I hope that it improves your living situation. It helps you redefine your relationship with your parents, whatever it may be. As always, if there is someone who you think needs to hear this episode,
研究领域，尤其是随着同居现象的增加，我们看到年轻人更频繁地搬回家住。我认为这一切都指向一个更广泛的社会转变，即20岁左右的年轻人很难像我们的父母当年那样独立。这并不是说我们不想独立，对吧？这是因为诸如财务、生活成本等一系列因素，与我们的人格以及我们所能做出的决定相互交织。所以我真心希望你喜欢这期节目。希望你学到了一些东西。希望它能改善你的居住环境。它能帮你重新定义你与父母的关系，无论那是什么。一如既往，如果你觉得有人需要听听这期节目，
maybe not your parents, maybe a friend, or someone like that, please feel free to share it with them. That is the main way that this show grows and reaches more people. Make sure you're following. You never know when a new episode might be one that you really need to hear and it pops up on your feed and I don't know, it becomes part of your day. So hit the follow button if you're on Spotify and subscribe, I think, if you're on Apple. I really need to brush up on my podcasting app knowledge. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you want to contribute more to this conversation, of course I would love to hear from you.
也许不是你的父母，而是一个朋友或类似的人，请随时分享给他们。这是这个节目能够成长并触及更多人的主要方式。确保你点了关注。你永远不知道哪期新节目正是你真正需要听的，它突然出现在你的信息流里，然后，我不知道，它成为了你日常生活的一部分。如果你在Spotify上，请点击关注按钮；如果你在Apple上，请点击订阅。我真的需要恶补一下我的播客应用知识了。如果你有节目建议，如果你想为这个对话贡献更多内容，我当然很乐意听到你的声音。
You can reach out to us at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. And as always, we will be back next week. Stay safe and be kind to yourself. Until then. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is a little. about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have
你可以在Instagram上通过 @That Psychology Podcast 联系我们。一如既往，我们下周见。照顾好自己，善待自己。回见。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门讨论黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都
anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
绝对不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你惹不起。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学到的教训》。2023年，美国单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the EyeHour Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
这里是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇异的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都跟同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我发誓，我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（Trust the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。